bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de parlement hebdo compagnie de mickaël
zeze bonjour comme chaque semaine nous
allons faire ensemble le tour de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
de la semaine avec bien sûr la
désignation de françois hollande comme
candidat socialiste à l'élection
présidentielle françois hollande
accueilli en héros au sénat et à
l'assemblée l'ump se dit qu'on va enfin
pouvoir parler d'autre chose enfin
presque
le parti présidentiel tenait cette
semaine une convention sur devinez quoi
le parti socialiste c'est le début de la
discussion budgétaire à l'assemblée à
budget placé sous le signe de
l'indispensable réduction des déficits
dans l'hémicycle gouvernement a surtout
parlé de l'impossible le projet
budgétaire évidemment de qui les
socialistes encore audi veut encore et
toujours cette fois au sénat la majorité
socialiste a repoussé son premier texte
depuis sa victoire aux élections
sénatoriales rejet de la proposition de
loi du député ump eric ciotti sur
l'encadrement militaire des mineurs est
avec nous pour parler de tous ces thèmes
jérôme chartier député ump du val d'oise
bonjour bonjour alors vous avez été élu
maire à 12,28 aux plus jeunes nous avait
même été assistant parlementaire ici au
sénat puis vous avez gravi les échelons
de votre parti politique l'ump un temps
aux charges de la modernisation de cette
vie politique et puis aujourd'hui vous
êtes porte parole du groupe ump sur le
budget qui est actuellement examiné à
l'assemblée au lundi dans les titres et
on va en parler tout au long de notre
émission alors avant de développer
l'actualité politique française un mot
bien sûr une réaction va vous demander
sur l'événement majeur de cette semaine
l'exécution du colonel kadhafi après son
arrestation par les forces du conseil
national de transition
c'est l'aboutissement d'une révolution
c'est aussi une image qui choque
l'onu demande
une enquête sur les conditions de sa
mort il faut connaître les conditions de
la mort du colonel kadhafi je crois que
c'est préférable simplement pour pouvoir
lever tout ce que l'on peut entendre ici
et là certains déjà parlé d'exécutions
par les militaires de l'otan bien sûr il
n'en est rien moi je ne souhaite pas
qu'on puisse imaginer un seul instant
que il ya eu un ordre a été donné
d'exécuter le colonel kadhafi si il y à
eut cette exécution elle semble être
manifestement populaire en tout cas il
ne faut pas faire oublier le fait que le
colonel kadhafi d'abord un tyran
quelqu'un qui a régné à me sans partage
sur son pays
parfois dans des conditions
inacceptables quand même si le principe
même de l'exécution est choquante qui
s'est bien passé qui sommes dans un état
de droit et bien sûr il vaut toujours
mieux en procès personnes dans un état
de droit comme la france peut préférer
l'exécution un procès nous sommes tous
pour un procès mais nous sommes en libye
nous sommes à syrte en l'occurrence à ce
moment là la limite en révolution dans
les révolutions il ya parfois des
exécutions
chacun d'eux c'est l'histoire de france
de l'enseignent on peut le regretter
mais mais en tout cas le constat il est
très important de faire la lumière sur
les conditions de cette exécution pour
qu'il n'y ait pas seul doute sur le fait
que l'otan souvent soit à l'origine leur
à présent et au pardon la réconciliation
qu'est ce qui va se passer à partir de
maintenant pour la france sur place en
libye
ce que je souhaite c'est que la france
continue à accompagner le processus de
démocratisation en libye c'est
nécessaire de telle sorte que la libye
puisse s'engager sur la voie de la
démocratie mais de surcroît que la
france continue à accompagner le
gouvernement libyen dans ses choix
industriels par exemple dans ses choix
économiques aussi la france la france a
des choses à faire surface
la france a des choses à frères faire
sur place même manifestement les libyens
le demande
eh bien il faut que nous répondu à leurs
attentes on va passer à l'actualité du
lundi qui a été dominée par la victoire
aux primaires de françois hollande
galvanisé par sa victoire le candidat ps
s'exprime devant ses troupes s'étaient
part dimanche soir à la maison de
l'amérique latine
il appelle un large rassemblement du ps
mais vous allez l'entendre sur sept
appellent également aux autres partis de
la gauche écoutez nous sommes simplement
maintenant dans l'obligation de nous
unir de nous rassembler et de faire
ensuite la marche vers l'élection
présidentielle
alors il y à la gauche et les
écologistes j'ai compris que les
écologistes avaient voulu peut-être un
moment s'immiscer dans nos débats
visiblement leur nombre n'a pas suffi
mais moi j'ai suffisamment de respect
pour les écologistes pour savoir qu'ils
ont leur place toute leur place dans le
rassemblement qu'il faudra construire
dans l'accord de gouvernement qu'il
faudra rechercher de même manière avec
le front de gauche il y aura des
frottements
on en connaît le candidat et il aime ce
type de confrontation et en même temps
c'est la gauche jérôme chartier
dans cette interview pas dans ceux de
large dialogue de françois hollande
auprès de ses troupes il a également
parlé de ceux qui ne savent plus qu'ils
sont à droite
bref il va sur ceux qui sont déçus du
sarkozysme ça vous fait par françois
hollande
maintenant ça me fait pas peur françois
hollande en tout cas je suis content que
les socialistes désigner leur candidat
il ya eu cette primaire c'était le choix
des socialistes de l'organiser c'est
très bien leur affaire et c'était un
programme de gauche contre un programme
de gauche une personne de gauche contre
un vide personne de bouche et il est
normal à l'issue de cette primaire qu'on
reprenne la parole
c'est notre responsabilité au fond le
débat démocratique chacun en convient
c'est entre la droite et la gauche
de tout temps c'est ainsi et les normal
que la vraie démocratie reprenne ses
droits
mais là c'est un appel du pied vers le
centre aux droits on sait qu il peut
mordre notamment sur un électorat qui
aurait pu voter pour nicolas sarkozy ou
pour jean louis borloo s'il avait été
candidat par exemple en tout cas
manifestement françois hollande le croit
moi je ne crois pas je pense à lui les
sandales achète semaine 64% second tour
sur un score quasi
soviétique on aurait pu dire à une
époque et on a même que les
sympathisants de jean louis borloo les
électeurs potentiels ne se sont pas
reportées pour la censure sur nicolas
sarkozy
au delà d'un score soviétique si on fait
un bref rappel de la vème république le
meilleur score si charles de gaulle 55%
vient ensuite la deuxième élection de
françois mitterrand 54%
enfin soyons salut de quoi parle-t-on
soit françois hollande est l'homme du
siècle c'est après tout pourquoi pas
mais plus sérieusement je crois que les
sondages d'aujourd'hui sur les
intentions de vote ne valent pas
tripette
chacun le sait attendons que la campagne
démenons surtout attend donc la campagne
présidentielle des morts attendons un
peu nicolas sarkozy c'est ce que je
serai annonce sa candidature à la
présidence de la république et à partir
de ce moment là nous aurons des vrais
sondages d'intentions de vote il peut
pas il peut rebondir à dans les
prochaines semaines il doit parler qu
est ce qu il doit faire nicolas sarkozy
il va surtout continuer à faire son
travail c'est là où les français
l'attendent et les présidents de la
république c'est un président de
république
exceptionnelle il faut qu'il continue à
l'être incarner cette responsabilité
telle qu'il incarne aujourd'hui et le
moment venu qu'il présente sa
candidature mais d'abord nous sommes
dans une situation de crise sans
précédent extrêmement forte c'est c'est
vraiment la prolongation de la crise de
2008 c'est un moment qui est cliquée
stratégique pour la france et pour
l'europe
il n'est pas question aujourd'hui les
dents puis surtout n'est pas question de
dun verser le calendrier le calendrier
c'est d'abord régler les problèmes de la
france et ensuite préparer l'élection
présidentielle et non la veille on va
passer la journée du mardi désole encore
parler de françois hollande et de sa
tournée parlementaire
le mardi ce sont les réunions de groupe
à l'assemblée comme au sénat le député
françois hollande est évidemment un
habitué de ces réunions au palais
bourbon
plus inhabituel il est d'abord passée au
sénat rencontre de vainqueur de ce
scrutin c'est un sujet signé yoan relate
jean baptiste daoulas et pierre lascars
il y a quelques semaines jean pierre bel
avait apporté son soutien à françois
hollande dans le bras de fer des
primaires aujourd'hui le premier
président le second aspirent à l'être et
les retrouvailles sont chaleureuses je
suis avec mes amis ici avec le nouveau
président du sénat celui qui a réussi ce
qu'aucun autre avant lui n'avait été
capable de réaliser c'est à dire une
alternance au sénat
donc je viens prendre un certain nombre
de conseils salut amical à une salle
conquise
derrière les portes la réunion ne durera
qu'un petit quart d'heure un quart
d'heure pour donner sa feuille de route
de candidats est lancé le sénat dans la
campagne sénat alors du changement
c'était donc le programme qui m'était
proposé préparé de la meilleure des
façons
non seulement la campagne présidentielle
mais l'alternance le changement
pressez le député hollande a déjà rendez
vous chez ses pairs à l'assemblée pour
un nouveau bain de foule
les soutiens de martine aubry sont là et
applaudissent après la primaire qui a
été fantastique
au moment de mobilisation et dynamique
on est en train de créer des passerelles
les liens entre les candidats du premier
du deuxième tour de façon à ce que il ne
manque pas un socialiste pour la
victoire mais deux
parmi les objectifs de françois hollande
m les parlementaires en première ligne
dans la conquête de l'elysée
certains des députés qui l'ont soutenu
pourrait d'ailleurs faire leur entrée
dès demain au bureau national du parti
socialiste qui la renvoie elles sont
portées par une sorte de vague
d'euphorie en ce mardi ça fait rêver un
député ump s'est maintenant vous
connaissez peut donc scellé qu'on
connaît très bien au contraire ça fait
des années qu'on les connaît ces moments
là ça fait maintenant il me semble la
troisième élection présidentielle qu'on
les connaît ces moments-là redon cet
automne mais nous avons nous avons un
contexte de majorité extrêmement
studieuse est extrêmement concentré sur
sur les problèmes on n'est pas nous
donne dans cette espèce d'euphorie
sympathique sais mais c'est la sphère
des socialistes je trouve en même temps
qu'elle est extrêmement décalé par
rapport à ce que ressentent les français
viseront ils ont organisé leur primaire
très bien et maintenant on est passé à
autre chose
les nombreux participer à cette primaire
et puis c'est un exercice de démocratie
mais en même temps est-ce que ça masqué
pour l'ump
les vrais problèmes de la france en
aucun cas nous on continue à s'en
préoccuper et de l'autre côté les
socialistes ont été totalement
concentrés sur leurs primaires on a
parfois l'impression qu'ils oubliaient
les vrais problèmes quels sont les vrais
problèmes des français citent l'emploi
c'est la crise de la dette souveraine
c'est les finances de la france c'est la
croissance française qui pour l'instant
n'est pas au niveau que l'on attendait
voilà quelles sont les priorités en
charge l'avenir de petites secondes
quand même sur la personnalité de
françois hollande nicolas sarkozy de
comparer un sucre et a récemment solide
à l'extérieur mais quand on le met dans
l'eau ils font est ce que vous êtes
d'accord un président de la république
est ce que c'est un candidat
qui pour vous est peut-être moins fort
que martine aubry je pense que c'est un
candidat qu'on va découvrir dans les
semaines qui viennent mais les premiers
pas du candidat françois hollande
narry femmes convaincre c'est un
candidat qui passe son temps à chercher
des compromis or lorsqu'on est candidat
à l'élection présidentielle
lorsqu'on décide de devenir président de
la république il faut savoir que il y
aura parfois pas de compromis qu'il y
aura une décision qu'il faudra l'assumer
et je n'ai pas encore vu françois
hollande dans l'exercice d'une décision
qu'il a subi il a été secrétaire général
du parti socialiste pendant des années
ça a été l'homme de tous les compromis
certains diront parfois des
compromissions mais ça va péter l'homme
des décisions attendre on sent bien
c'est là dessus que se concentreront les
attaques lors de la période parce que
c'est simplement ce qui se révèle sa
personnalité
c'est l'un de ses principaux traits de
caractère et
et en même temps cela semble assez
incompatible avec la responsabilité
présidentielle à responsabilités
présidentielles et nicolas sarkozy le
prouve tous les jours
c'est une responsabilité fait de
décisions qui parfois sont impopulaires
mais qui sont nécessaires alors on voit
bien les angles d'attaqué d'ailleurs
c'était la réplique de l'ump cette
semaine une convention pour décortiquer
le projet socialiste des ministres des
parlementaires venus par dizaines dans
un grand salon parisien pendant deux
heures
le but de cette opération est à dire
tout le mal qu'il pensait du candidat
françois hollande et du projet du parti
socialiste
reportage en main andrieu et mario le
faire c'est le deuxième temps de la
riposte une convention l'ump ciblées sur
le projet du parti socialiste
l'objectif reconquérir l'espace
médiatique et surtout attaqué la
crédibilité de leurs adversaires en 2012
l'aptitude au commandement surtout dans
ces périodes difficiles c'est la
démonstration
pour françois hollande ou non de sa
capacité à préconiser des décisions
courageuses au risque d'être impopulaire
or vous savez ce que l'on dit de
françois hollande c'est qu'il est habile
que il fait même des blagues parfois ce
qui est sympathique mais en revanche
personne ne dit jamais qu'il est
courageux pas courageux ambiguë pour la
majorité les attaques sur le candidat et
le programme sont indissociables c'est
surtout le prix à payer
après le processus des primaires quel
prix vont lui faire payer
allez monsieur mélenchon pour son
soutient madame joly sur le nucléaire
est aussi monsieur montebourg
monsieur hollande il veut plaire à tout
le monde pouvait pas plaire à tout le
monde en faisant de la politique ça vous
permet peut-être de réussir la primaire
au sein du ps mais c'est pas ça qui
permet d'être présent la république
emploi pouvoir d'achat sécurité
plusieurs ministres ont fait le
déplacement pour décortiquer chaque
mesure la chiffrer et la décrédibiliser
c'est un exercice de vérité pour
démontrer qu'aujourd'hui le programme du
parti socialiste nous conduirait très
vite vers à la situation dans laquelle
s'est trouvée la grèce après la gestion
socialiste ou le portugal avec les mêmes
solutions qui conduirait aux mêmes maux
pour autant pas question d'accélérer le
calendrier nicolas sarkozy reste un
candidat probable mais pas officiel
quant au projet de l'ump pour 2012 il ne
sera pas validé avant la fin de l'année
alors jérôme chartier
pendant toutes quasiment trois semaines
on entendu l'ump car on parle trop du
parti socialiste on parle trop du parti
socialiste et vous faites une convention
pour parler de quoi
du projet du parti socialiste on
comprend pas bien si je pense que vous
comprenez très bien c'est notre
responsabilité de parler du projet ce
que l'on a reproché à cette primaire
c'est qu'au fond c'était l'histoire du
parti socialiste entre lui mais c'est
passé un début de débat démocratique
le débat démocratique n'est pas de
savoir comment est-ce que ce pass
l'organisation de la sélection du
candidat l'intérieur d'un parti c'est la
sphère du parti s'ils font leur primaire
de façon renouvelée élargi c'est leur
affaire
nous notre affaire c'est pas de
critiquer ou non leurs primaires c'est
de discuter avec eux de leurs
propositions de leurs solutions et c'est
ce qu'on a fait valoir que le projet
n'est pas forcément celui du candidat
françois hollande pendant des semaines
et des mois les socialistes nous ont
expliqué que leur projet résulte est là
processus de démocratie interne
formidable c'était un vrai exemple de
démocratie participative et voilà que
monsieur hollande décidera et de tirer
un trait sur ce projet alors que tous
les candidats ont dit que le projet
socialiste serait leur moi je rêve ou ne
plus comprendre si finalement pendant
des mois la crise économique et que ce
travail ne sert à rien que monsieur
hollande de 10 mais qu'il le dise
maintenant et par conséquent nous ne
craignons plus projet puisqu'il n'y aura
plus le web n'aura plus lieu d'être
mais pour l'instant c'est toujours le
projet du parti socialiste et que je
sache monsieur hollande ne l'a jamais
démentie en tout cas françois hollande
réussi un exploit en la vidant le sujet
c'est de mettre d'accord
xavier bertrand et jean françois copé ce
qui est assez rare vous croyez pas qu'on
aurait plus envie de vous entendre sur
votre propre projet maintenant plutôt
que sur une critique comme sa partie des
autres de problèmes des autres
je n'en suis pas certain parce que je
pense que l'une de nos responsabilités
c'est d'expliciter d'analysé
et d'émettre des critiques sur le projet
de l'adversaire c'est normal on est là
pour ça parce que si nous ne le faisons
pas alors qui va le faire les
socialistes même
manifestement ils vont pas critiquer
leur propre projet ça serait stupéfiant
et puisque les socialistes depuis cinq
ans ne prennent pas suffisamment de
temps voir tout leur temps à critiquer
toutes les propositions du gouvernement
je dirais même qu'ils ne font que ça
enfin comme crazy médicaux trop
critiques ces cinq ans en permanence
donc cette campagne sera à la fois la
présentation des projets de chacun des
candidats
la présentation de la vision du candidat
mais aussi bien sûr l'explication du
projet de la partie adverse
l'explicitation pour les français de
telle sorte que les français puissent
percevoir les différences entre les
projets ça aussi c'est la responsabilité
des partis politiques mot tout de même
sur la forme de cette convention avec ce
conteur qui déroulaient ça rappelle une
émission qui passait sur sur les chaînes
publiques électives mauvais goût du
showbiz pas du tout il ya une partie qui
est comme ça qu'ils médiatique
aujourd'hui dans la politique et chacun
de ces chacals observe et chacun est
obligé de s'adapter c'est l'évolution de
la vie politique
donc à nous aussi d'en tirer les
conséquences ça veut dire quoi cette
convention pour il y avait le côté
ludique du compteur mais qui était le
clin d'oeil est que chacun bien compris
comme un clin d'oeil
et puis il y avait les séquences très
courtes minutes oui c'était plutôt
amusant avec ce bruit caisse
enregistreuse
on en rediscutera si vous voulez voir
mais tout le monde en tout cas en
assurés parce que c'était vraiment le
côté ludique
en revanche il y avait les séquences
très courtes des parlementaires et vous
le savez pour faire taire un
parlementaire parfois c'est compliqué
l'animateur de haute lutte il y est
parvenu en réduisant les propos à 2
minutes ce qui a donné une convention
extrêmement moderne extrêmement enlevé
extrêmement dynamique et c'est vrai
nettement plus télévisuelle que d'autres
conférences il faut le reconnaître le
but c'était de faire de la télé vidéo
c'est à dire que notre but aussi c'est
de nous adapter aujourd'hui à la société
moderne et la société moderne il faut le
reconnaître et on le savait bien passe
par la télévision
comme vous vous perfectionner dans le
show télévisé finalement dans le show
télévisé c'est peut être faudra t il
en tout cas on est obligé d'utiliser les
médias tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui
médias sur la presse écrite mais qui a
des difficultés chacun observe son la
presse internet qui est en croissance
fantastique considérable et la presse
audiovisuelle
d'après ce audio et la presse
audiovisuelle qui n'a jamais été
démentie dans son efficacité et surtout
dans sa performance auprès des français
donc à nous de nous adapter à cela
allait en tout cas mardi cette obsession
socialiste de l'ump on la sentait aussi
à l'assemblée petites phrases assassines
lors des questions au gouvernement
et cela continue quand s'ouvre en fin
d'après-midi la discussion sur le budget
écoutez cet échange entre le ministre de
l'économie et le président du groupe
socialiste projet socialiste c'est le
boulet de martine aubry au pied de
françois hollande
comment pouvez vous proposer
simultanément la remise en cause de la
réforme des retraites et le retour à 60
ans c'est 48 milliards 2012 2015
la remise en cause de la révision
générale des politiques publiques
c'est plus de 4 milliards la proposition
de 200000 contrat de génération on prend
même pas ce que ça veut dire ce terme
c'est plus de 8 milliards
60000 postes supplémentaires dans
l'éducation nationale c'est plus de deux
milliards et demi ces quatre mesures
ces quatre seules mesures constituent en
eux-mêmes le caractère de discrédit du
projet que vous portez que vous défendez
que vous continuez de défendre ici même
et je n'en doute pas que vous continuez
de défendre dans un aveuglement et une
cécité incroyable
nous sommes à l'assemblée nationale
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés chers collègues et
nous entendons le ministre de l'économie
qui se trompent d'endroits qui se
croient aujourd'hui à la convention
nationale de l'ump consacrée à la mise
en coupe réglée du projet du parti
socialiste et les attaques qui n'ont
aucun sens caricature elle contre le
candidat du parti socialiste françois
hollande
est-ce que vous mesurez le côté presque
pathétique de votre intervention c'est
votre responsabilité
c'est votre bilan alors revenez un peu
aux réalités monsieur le président afin
que le gouvernement retrouve un peu plus
de sérénité et de dignité dans un débat
qui est consacrée à la loi de finances
je demandais suspension de séance
voilà un peu agité donc on le voit vous
même qui est porte parole de l'ump sur
le budget à l'assemblée
vous êtes monté au créneau ce jour là
vous avez demandé à valérie pécresse
si elle comptait demander à françois
hollande de ne pas appliquer ces projets
en question un peu telle est l'idée
voilà c'était ce n'est pas une question
du tout vous dire c'est un micro une
question chez chaque elle a senti ces
tests c'était surtout le lourd de telle
sorte que en rond ont soulevé
manifestement la cohérence entre le
discours du candidat françois hollande
qui voulait maîtriser la dépense
publique et le projet peu socialiste
tellement faramineux en termes de
dépenses mais on en revient à la même
question c'était encore une bonne idée
la 2de d'ouvrir sa discussion budgétaire
si importante dans les conditions qu'on
connaît par une attaque contre les
propositions ps plutôt que de partir sur
le sur votre propre budget 2010 quel est
le contexte le contexte vous le savez
c'est l'annoncé faite cette semaine de
l' agence moody's une période
d'observation de trois mois de la france
pour savoir si oui ou non la france peut
tenir son triple a avec la dégradation
de la conjoncture internationale
donc il était très important de
manifester de choses hein la
détermination du gouvernement sur la
tenue de la réduction de déficit public
cette essence pour l'incendié ce mardi
là je peux vous confirmer que je peux
vous confirmer que
c'est justement mais j'y viens j'y viens
je peux vous confirmer c'était vraiment
dans les propos de ministres aussi mais
ils étaient moins fils b on va dire et
deuxième élément parce que les sondages
sont là et puis vous en parler
suffisamment de marquer le fait que nous
sommes contre le projet socialiste pour
qu'il y ait aucun doute dans l'état
lisons lara cours et c'est le message
qui est passé sept seulement car il ya
la baisse mais qui n'y aucun doute dans
l'esprit des analystes de moody's que
nous sommes contre toute dérive des
finances publiques et c'était l'occasion
de le dire et de le redire ces trois
mois sont trois mois déterminant pour la
france le triple a n'est jamais donnée
d'office il est démontré
nous avons tous les moyens pour le
démontrer mais d'un autre côté et chacun
peut lire les sondages si les
socialistes viennent aux responsabilités
c'est quasiment mécaniquement la perte
du triple a avec un projet pareil il
faut tout faire pour sauver notre triple
a mais c'est pourquoi ce stade où
vraiment c'est pas seulement une sorte
d'incantation triple triple à c'est
l'assurance des meilleures conditions de
refinancement de la dette française on
emprunte chaque année 220 milliards
d'euros sur les marchés
si vous payez 220 milliards 1 % en plus
vous avez calculé ces 2,2 milliards par
an de plus ça veut dire que tous les
efforts que vous pouvez faire pour
réduire la dépense publique par exemple
ils seront neutralisées par
l'augmentation des taux d'intérêt pour
financer votre dette
alors évidemment on va parler du budget
dans un instant au jeudi mais laboriel
mercredi le sénat retoque le texte sur
les mineurs délinquants
c'est l'un des premiers effets du sénat
passé à gauche la commission des lois a
rejeté la proposition de loi sur
l'encadrement militaire des mineurs
délinquants elle a par contre été déjà
voté la semaine dernière à l'assemblée
nationale un refus de pure forme puisque
l'as anglais aura le dernier mot mais un
acte politique fondateur pour ce nouveau
sénat les explications de faustine saint
geniès la nouvelle majorité du sénat a
dit non non à l'encadrement militaire
des délinquants mineurs
une proposition de loi du député ump
eric ciotti adopté par l'assemblée
nationale la semaine dernière
proposition qualifiée d' affichage par
le groupe socialiste au sénat ce texte
c'est du bricolage il n'est ni fait ni à
faire
il a été improvisé c'est une sorte de
texte d'affichage publicitaire au slogan
tout ce que vous voulez et pendant ce
temps là on ne donne pas les moyens en
particulier les moyens en terme
d'éducateur parce que pour lutter contre
la délinquance des mineurs il faut des
hommes et des femmes sur le terrain
une idée pourtant ancien lancé par
ségolène royal alors candidate à la
présidentielle
pour ces élèves là moi je propose le
placement d'office dans un service à
encadrement militaire
depuis l'idée a fait son chemin dans les
rangs de la gauche avant d'être récupéré
par le député des alpes maritimes
dans un rapport sur l'exécution des
peines remis à nicolas sarkozy avec ce
projet qui peut surprendre
le sénat a imprimé sa marque à sept mois
de la présidentielle
alors bien sûr ce texte sera débattu en
séance publique le 25 octobre il a de
fortes chances d'être rejeté c'est les
premiers effets donc du sénat passé à
gauche un nombre de textes qui risque
d'être rejeté puis certains sont adoptés
d'ailleurs la grande surprise des
socialistes de l'assemblée nationale par
exemple le projet de loi pour apporter
la garantie de l'état à dexia a été
adopté par la dilution des militaires
avec une commission en dehors de nous
vendre eurosic battant les socialistes
et par le groupe lui-même avait un
amendement socialiste sur la
responsabilité
je n'ai pas de bonus en cas de oui mais
en mettant d'abord c'est un amendement
que nous avions nous-mêmes adoptée en
2008 au coeur de la crise financière
donc c'était pas un avocat comme ça tu
es une surprise la cmp a finalisé
l'accord entre l'assemblée nationale et
le sénat mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que trois jours avant
lorsque l'opposition socialiste à
l'assemblée nationale refusé de voter ce
projet de loi apportant la garantie de
l'état pour dexia et bien trois jours
après les socialistes de senna eux l'ont
voté donc il ya parfois des surprises
dans l'organisation du parti socialiste
face à certains projets devant soutient
aujourd'hui les socialistes du risque
d'y avoir des versions plutôt négatif
sur le budget ou sur le projet de loi de
finances sera qu environ à ce moment là
nous avons encore quelques semaines pour
en discuter mais mais après tout je
dirais rien d'officiel n'est pas
possible lorsque je vois l'esprit de de
leur vie de travail et du groupe
socialiste au sénat je me dis qu'il
devrait bien inspiré le groupe
socialiste à l'assemblée nationale
alors toujours ce mercredi l assemblage
aux quartiers savez-vous qui sont les
humanistes non nous le dire je savais
pas alors c'est un groupe de députés ump
figurez-vous avec à leur tête jean
leonetti et marc laffineur qui ont
décidé de créer un mouvement pour mettre
en avant une droite modérée il tenait
une conférence de presse pour expliquer
leurs idées et en face le même jour il y
avait un point presse de la droite
populaire à droite de l'ump qui lance
elle une pétition contre le droit de
vote des étrangers
l'ump d'un bout à l'autre de l'échiquier
est un sujet de bérangère d'un glace
closets pouvoir suivre donc recueillir
autant de signatures que les primaires
socialistes
thierry mariani met la barre haut en
lançant sa pétition le chef de file de
la droite populaire veut ainsi alerter
les français sur ce point du programme
socialiste
le droit pour les étrangers de voter et
de se faire élire aux élections locales
dès lors qu'ils ont cinq ans de
résidence sur le territoire
une possibilité que nicolas sarkozy
avait un temps évoquée mais d'après son
ministre des transports il y est
aujourd'hui clairement opposés
et soutient la pétition on peut devenir
français au bout de cinq ans à condition
de parler le français d'être intégrés et
en clair d'avoir respecté les lois de la
république
si on n'est pas français au bout de dix
ans soit d'une des trois conditions qui
est pas remplie
soit tout simplement c'est un choix
qu'on a fait c'est tout à fait
respectable mais dans ce cas là on n'a
pas le droit de vote le droit de vote
doit rester intimement lié la
nationalité française lors de la
campagne pour la primaire martine aubry
est souvent rappelé ce combat de longue
date pour elle
mais si la droite populaire signe là un
nouveau coup médiatique
à l'ump tout le monde ne partage pas
cette position
ainsi marc laffineur cofondateur il y à
quelques jours de la droite humaniste
nouveaux courants de l'ump affirme
clairement avoir une vision beaucoup
plus large la citoyenneté
à partir du moment où on paye des impôts
dans une commune et qu'on y vit depuis
plus de cinq ans encore une fois ça me
paraît pas anormal que l'on puisse et
bien voter pour les élections locales
à condition bien entendu qui est la
réciprocité dans le pays d'origine sinon
ça n'a aucun sens ce texte proposé par
le gouvernement jospin en 2000 avait été
votée à l'assemblée mais n'avait pas été
débattue au sénat
avec le basculement de la haute
assemblée les socialistes ont clairement
fait du vote des étrangers
l'une de leurs priorités pour l'après
2012 alors plusieurs tendances à l'ump
c'est normal on sait où vous êtes plutôt
populaire plutôt droite humaniste où
vous situez où sur 7 sur cet échiquier
écoutez je me sens très humaniste
populaire donc j'espère que ça existe au
fond vous savez c'est des nuances et je
trouve que c'est bien que ça existe au
début de l'ump en 2002 nous avions des
clubs c'est les clubs ça servait à quoi
ça servait à ce que chacun puisse
exprimer sa sensibilité il c'était une
démarche très cohérentes avec celles de
l'union pour un mouvement populaire et
je souhaite au fond que ces mouvements
là qui ressort d'un des clubs à s'y
méprendre continue se développe
de la sorte possibilité d'effets au
contraire que les sensibilités
s'expriment au sein de l'ump est une
c'est une chose que ce soit sur ces
sujets que ce soit sur d'autres sujets
encore il faut que ça vive parce qu'un
mouvement politique ça doit vivre ce
droit de vote des étrangers
notre pays jean le partage et je le
reconnais les élections locales par
exemple aujourd'hui enfin sans doute on
ne le dit pas suffisamment mais pour les
élections locales ça existe le droit de
vote des étrangers notamment le propos
des des citoyens de l'union européenne
et ça me semble très bien de limiter aux
citoyens de l'union européenne parce
qu'il faut qu'on marque un avantage
d'appartenir à l'union européenne
et ça c'est une forme davantage que je
trouve extrêmement significatif tant moi
je suis attaché aux principes du droit
de vote pour une personne qui a la
nationalité d'un autre côté je suis
sensible à ce que dit marc laffineur sur
l'esprit de citoyenneté c'est vrai à
l'esprit de citoyenneté
c'est un esprit de responsabilité mais
j'estime qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'étrangers qui sont en situation
régulière sur le territoire national est
évidemment ont cet esprit de
responsabilité et au fond de citoyenneté
est ce que pour autant il faut leur
confie le droit de vote
alors je me demanderais quelle serait la
différence entre être citoyen français
et être un citoyen étranger en cession
légale sur la victoire nationale abc
parce que vous n'êtes pas bien quand
elle m'a pas bien écouté je ne vous
répondent en développement que j'étais
pour une solution que le citoyen
français citoyens français mais le droit
de vote aux citoyens français c'est
celui qui a la nationalité française
même pour ceux qui payent des impôts
mais le fait de payer des impôts c'est
le fait de payer des impôts c'est aussi
la contrepartie de tous les services que
vous offre la société française je vous
rappelle que si vous êtes malade vous
avez une sécurité sociale que si on vous
vole votre porte monnaie vous pouvez
porter plainte effet recherché celui qui
voulait voler je vous rappelle que si
vous avez un membre de la famille qui
est malade
la sécurité sociale joue aussi pour
votre membres de la famille votre enfant
qui est malade bref poupées les impôts
pour tout cela et ça me semble
parfaitement légitime de payer des
impôts
je pense que la contrepartie du vote ce
n'est pas le fait de payer l'impôt je
paye des impôts donc je vote non c'est
je vote parce que j'ai la nationalité
française et que je veux diriger mon
pays dans une certaine direction
vous disiez vous visitez
humaniste populaire mais cette droite
populaire est ce qu'il est si bon de
l'entendre autant pour l'ump est ce que
ce n'est pas une dérive vue et un ton de
la campagne qui va être donnée aussi pas
du tout l on a beaucoup entendu parce
qu'elle était seule au fond le sans
doute les équipes veulent encadrer
aujourd'hui cette grosse faute une
erreur de la mersey les humanistes d'un
sarrau de tendance c'est de ne pas avoir
exprimé leur sensibilité alors qu'elle
aurait dû le faire et maintenant les
humanistes existe est une très bonne
chose
je voudrais que d'autres tendances
existe encore davantage puisse servir à
la mi mars on ne s'entendra mais
pourquoi montrer la diversité est ce que
c'est de la cacophonie
non il faut au contraire que chacun se
sente représentée au sein de l'ump
c'est nettement plus important et je
trouve qu'on avait très bien réussi à le
faire
en 2002 il faut qu'on retrouve cet
esprit de 2002 où nous avions réussi
sept ump très large avec l'expression
toutes les sensibilités il est pas là
l'esprit de 2002 n'est plus là je vous
le dis je pense qu'on est vraiment en
train de le retrouver
c'était très caractéristique lors de la
convention la semaine dernière et moi ce
qui m'a marqué c'est tant de
personnalités du mouvement qui étaient
présentes qui se sont toutes exprimé
dans un esprit extrêmement positif
extrêmement construit oui c'était
vraiment l'esprit de 2002 qu'ils
appellent la convention sur la place
oui la convention seule pièce très
positif parce que vous n'avez pas suivi
avec la tension on la diffuse
oui c'est vrai mais ce que vous l'avez
regardé ou écouté toujours félicité ça
au nord votre conscience progrès social
mais mais je dois vous dire que moi ce
que j'en pense que j'en ai ressenti sur
place c'est justement cette atmosphère
très positif de chaque fois bon il y
avait la critique bien sûr mais encore
une fois moi je les assume cette
critique du projet socialiste c'est
l'une de notre responsabilité politique
à cette atmosphère positive vous n'êtes
pas nombreux à accepter ou en tout cas à
dire la même chose au sein de l'ump qui
a dit la caution de 2000 $ parce que
parfois il y a des idia t&d des
personnalités qui sont un peu déçus
rachida dati est un peu déçu en ce
moment de l'arrivée de françois fillon à
paris vous le savez que moi donc c'est
vrai françois fillon à paris fillonistes
proche de françois fillon que c'est bien
évidemment une bonne chose pour paris
françois fillon sont exprimés expliqué
auprès des sarthois
je trouve qu'il a trouvé les bons mots
pour pouvoir le dire et tant que
nouvelle aventure qui commence pour lui
je suis très heureux et je crois que
beaucoup de parisiens sont très heureux
en tout cas tous les parisiens que je
croise viennent m'en parler parce qu'ils
connaissent la proximité avec le premier
ministre et vient de me dire à quel
point ils sont heureux que françois
fillon alors on verra ça en 2012 a les
jambes sortie on va passer au jeudi on
reparle du budget pas du projet
socialiste cette fois mais vraiment du
projet de budget 2012
en ce jeudi c'est la taxation des hauts
revenus qui est au programme députés ump
avaient rédigé deux amendements visant à
alourdir la fiscalité des plus riches
amendement écarté compte rendu de la
séance avec jean baptiste daoulas
jusqu'au bout michel piron a défendu sa
proposition de créer une nouvelle
tranche d'impôt de 40 6 % sur les
revenus supérieurs à 150 mille euros par
part les en fin de soirée il retire son
amendement des x et regrette qu'en effet
une partie importante dans la majorité
n'ait pas été comprise ou entendues au
sens comprise
c'est un regret qui à mon avis pentures
un amendement qui avait beaucoup de sens
et qui aurait donné beaucoup de sens à
tous les efforts que vous demandiez en
ce moment à l'ensemble des français
interpellé la ministre du budget défend
la position du gouvernement
chiffres à l'appui valérie pécresse
affirme que la taxe exceptionnelle sur
les hauts revenus est une meilleure
solution pour remplir les caisses de
l'état
l'amendement de michel piron que la
michel piron nous propose rapport 365
millions d'euros au budget de l'état
l'amendement que vous venez d'adopter
importe 420 millions d'euros ça veut
dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'en réalité la
contribution exceptionnelle de
solidarité va frapper beaucoup plus
durement les ménages qui sont plus aisés
la taxe exceptionnelle sera de 3% pour
les revenus de 250 mille à cinq cent
mille euros et de 4% au-delà de 500
mille euros
elle devrait toucher entre 26 et 27
mille foyers en france et ramener près
de 410 millions d'euros dans les caisses
de l'état une mesure cosmétique pour la
gauche le socialiste henri emmanuelli
fait le lien entre cette nouvelle taxe
et l'allègement de l'impôt sur la
fortune
votée au printemps vous avez sorti la
moitié des contribuables isf
d'imposition à l'impôt sur la fortune
que ça a coûté 1 milliard vitalité et
donc ça leur rapporte un milliard huit à
eux et tout ce cinéma ce soir
tout ce cirque c'est pour nous expliquer
qu'on va leur prendre 400 millions
on soutient l'opposition a repris à son
compte l'amendement de michel piron
sans surprise il a été rejeté le 88
alors à huis clos lors de votre réunion
de groupe mardi matin il y avait
françois fillon et vous étiez à cette
réunion
il paraît qu'il a vraiment été très
catégorique pas question de taxer plus
les riches c'est vrai mais écoutez c'est
exactement le contraire qui se produit
puisque rotax davantage ce qui était
prévu donc sans les amendements qui ont
été dit ce qui était dit surtout c'est
qu'on ne touche pas à l'impôt sur le
revenu puisque badgés
quémard supplémentaires ce que michel
piron voulais c'était créer une tranche
supplémentaire au titre de l'impôt sur
le revenu bon et nous depuis 2007
on est d'accord sur le fait que si on
doit retoucher là pour seul revenu c'est
le cadre d'une revue générale des
prélèvements obligatoires c'est à dire
une réforme fiscale qui modernise la
fiscalité française
nous en sommes parfaitement convaincu on
a besoin de moderniser cette fiscalité
il faut le faire de façon cohérente et
bien travaillé françois fillon a
visiblement fait très peur aux députés
gameplay puisque il y avait quand même
pas mal de signataires de cet amendement
de monsieur pierre anselme et à la fin
c'est retrouver un petit peu seul face à
cet amendement qui donc a été oui parce
que on parce que depuis des semaines la
majorité travaille pour essayer de
trouver une solution juste qui demande
aux français les plus aisés de marquer
un effort de solidarité envers la nation
française toute entière pour revenir à
un déficit acceptable je dire acceptable
par le rock mais acceptable aussi
aujourd'hui par les investisseurs
financiers qui achètent des titres de
dette française c'est ces deux personnes
que l'on regarde aujourd'hui s'agissant
de la réduction des déficits publics on
est bien tous les parts et mentale b ont
été convaincus par les solutions que
l'on n'a apporté qui sont à la fois
cette accession 3% 4 % qui viennent
s'ajouter à toutes les mesures que nous
avons prises au moment de la réforme de
l'isf puisque comme au rythme annuel ils
oublient souvent la légende de l'usf est
totalement financée par des prélèvements
supplémentaires auprès des personnes qui
paient l'isf donc en vérité c'est
exactement la même somme que l'on
perçoit mais on l'aperçoit de façon
différente et sur le 1000 mg de l'argent
pour les caser sur le lien on aurait
très bien pu consulter il sauf que là
aujourd'hui on va plus loin parce que on
va demander 420 millions supplémentaires
aux français les plus aisés
et cela on estime légitime de le faire
du fait de la situation des finances
publiques l'allégement d'impôt sur la
fortune 900 millions par an de manque
dans laquelle elle est à vous confirmer
que oui je confirme
mais je confirme aussi que cet argent là
se retrouvent dans les caisses de l'état
par des prélèvements supplémentaires par
ample au titre de l'impôt sur les
transmissions puisque lorsque vous venez
à décéder bien lorsque vous avez un
patrimoine de plus de 4 millions d'euros
vous êtes taxées plus fortement à
hauteur de 4% de plus et est donc par
conséquent c'est la même somme
ces 900 millions que vous retrouvez dans
le budget de l'état
différemment perçue auprès du même
public c'était ça tout l'esprit de la
réforme de la sfc la première réforme
fiscale qui est financée à l'euro l'euro
par des prélèvements sur le même public
voilà cette grande évolution est ce que
j'appelle une modernisation fiscale
monsieur emmanuelli oublie toujours de
le dire parce qu'il a surtout envie de
créer de la polémique à vous parler des
critiques du parti socialiste vous
propose d'écouter le président de la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
jérôme cahuzac
ce budget ne permettra pas à notre pays
de procéder aux nécessaires ajustements
budgétaires pour la raison essentielle
qui est que ce budget ne fait rien pour
la croissance fondé sur une prévision de
1 75% de croissance chacun sait que
l'année prochaine
dans le meilleur des cas ce sera la
moitié est avec cette croissance là nous
ne pourrons tenir nos objectifs
alors oui effectivement sur nos temps
jérôme cahuzac une croissance qui serait
revenu à près de 0,9 sur l'entente
osciller les spécialistes pourquoi ne
pas dire clairement on va faire des
mesures d'austérité un plan de rigueur
éparses contre ce message peut être
entendu des français ville comme vous le
savez les français peuvent supporter la
vérité depuis bien longtemps maintenant
sa fin cela fait des années qu'ils
supportent la vérité il pourrait encore
aujourd'hui supporter la vérité
ils demandent même je dirais que cela
parce qu'ils ont soupé pendant des
années qu'on leur raconte des histoires
et pour découvrir ensuite que ce n'était
que des histoires 2006 de comédie
cocasse la croissance on avait peur que
les français ne réagissent mal par
rapport à ça qu'ils en consomment plus
non ce qu'il ne faut juger
faire lorsqu'on prépare un budget
lorsqu'on prépare une perspective de
croissance c'est de vouloir être
excessivement pessimiste pourquoi parce
que ça ne sert à rien d'abord parce que
dans l'âme la formation d'une croissance
il y a incontestablement un élément
psychologique qui joue de tout temps ça
a joué il est important d'avoir un
discours juste surtout juste pas
optimiste non plus parce que vous n'êtes
pas cru et ce discours de vérité
exactement ils se disent qu'au vue s'il
doit être revu en fonction des nouvelles
circonstances économiques qu'est ce que
le gouvernement a fait qu'est ce qu'on a
fait au mois d'août dernier le 24 août
le 24 août françois fillon tire les
conséquences de la dégradation de la
conjoncture internationale et donc par
conséquent pour tenir le cap de
réduction du déficit à 5 7% du pib pour
l'année 2011 il prend des mesures sans
précédent de telle sorte qu'on tienne le
cadre de la réduction est appelée appelé
mesure est la taxe sur les plus values
immobilières sur les résidences
secondaires les avec les propriétaires
de résidences secondaires ils vont vous
écrit jean chartier la taxe sur les
sodas ce que c'est obligatoire
mais c'est obligatoire parce que ça
rapporte de 140 millions d'euros et que
c'est une très grosse cette décla 240
millions d'euros c'est pas des
mesurettes
ce n'est pas ce ceux qui croient qu'il
ya des taxes qui existent et qui vont
rapporter d'un seul coup d'un seul 5
milliards d'euros alors il faut donner
le nom de ces personnes et ensuite il
faut me donner la mesure qu'il propose
est dicté par monsieur martin et se dit
qu'il y aura un collectif budgétaire
voilà
alors qu'ils sauront de demander aux
français en 2012 au moins pour 5
milliards
mais j'aime qu'il y aura un nouveau
collectif budgétaire parce qu'il est
traditionnelle et lyon en fin d'année
nous en aurons comme chaque année début
décembre il sera bien l'occasion de
début décembre nous aurons l'occasion de
voir si la perspective de croissance
pour 2011 est tenu et de voir s'il y a
lieu de réviser la perspective de
croissance pour 2005 milliards à trouver
en plus s'il y assemble un chiffre
similaire dégradation de mettons qu'on
passe de 1,75 à les 1,50 mettons et bien
le budget actuel tient pour 1 5% de
croissance cela était confirmé par le
premier ministre voici quelques jours
donc on est cohérent avec cette
trajectoire avec 2 5% de croissance s'il
y a moins de croissance et bien dans ce
cas là nous prendrons les mesures qui
s'imposent mais il ya un objectif c'est
de ne pas dériver de la réduction du
déficit public jarty on va finir cette
émission beaucoup plus en douceur avec
le carnet rose
la naissance d'une petite sarkozy giulia
qui est né à la clinique de la muette la
fois d'histoire un petit réaction très
rapide
je suis très heureux très heureux pour
nicolas sarkozy pour pour carla sarkozy
c'est un vrai bonheur
voilà merci c'est là dessus que nous
terminaux merci d'être venus dans cette
émission chez nous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine aux gardes même lieu
même heure évidemment au revoir